This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the 1960s, the psychologist Elizabeth Kubla Ross was studying patients with terminal illnesses. She noticed a pattern as they came to terms with their mortality. The patients seemed to go through different psychological phases. Elizabeth Kubla Ross eventually classified these phases into what she called the five stages of grief, denial, anger, bargaining, depression, and acceptance. The five stages were intuitively appealing and offered people a way to understand a complex experience. Very quickly, the simplicity of this framework began to seep into popular culture. Books, TV shows, and later countless YouTube videos. Your mind is protecting you by completely denying the reality.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。20世纪60年代，心理学家伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯正在研究身患绝症的患者。她在这些患者接受死亡现实的过程中注意到了一种规律。患者们似乎会经历不同的心理阶段。伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯最终将这些阶段归纳为她所称的悲伤的五个阶段：否认、愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁和接受。这五个阶段具有直观的吸引力，为人们提供了一种理解复杂体验的方式。很快，这种框架的简单性便开始渗透到流行文化中。书籍、电视节目，以及后来无数的YouTube视频。你的大脑正在通过完全否认现实来保护你。
Numbness may follow its nature's way of letting you deal only with your emotions that you're capable of handling. that you're capable of handling. As often happens, a system that was designed to be descriptive became prescriptive. The five stages translated into popular culture morphed into a model that told people they should expect to feel certain emotions and that their experience of grief would be a journey from one stage to the next. Finally, five is acceptance.
麻木可能会随之而来，这是大脑让你只去处理那些你能够承受的情绪的一种自然方式。正如经常发生的那样，一个旨在进行描述的系统变成了规定性的系统。这五个阶段在流行文化中演变成了一个模型，它告诉人们，他们应该预期自己会感受到某些情绪，并且他们体验悲伤的过程将是从一个阶段到下一个阶段的旅程。最后，第五阶段是接受。
It's the fifth stage and this is the end game here. And it is the result of all the stages of your grief. Over time, the five stage model of grief became so ingrained in people's minds that new insights, based on rigorous research, did not get as much airtime. For decades, the popular understanding of what we feel when we grieve was largely drawn from the five stages model.
这是第五阶段，也是这里的终局。它是你所有悲伤阶段的结果。随着时间的推移，悲伤的五阶段模型在人们心中根深蒂固，以至于基于严谨研究的新见解没有得到那么多的关注。几十年来，大众对我们悲伤时感受的理解很大程度上都取材于五阶段模型。
Anyone who's ever been bereaved will know that people tell you about them, they expect you to go through them, and pretty quickly I became frustrated with them because I don't want to be told what I'm going to feel. I am desperate to know what I can do to help us all adapt to this terrible loss. Today we bring you the story of a researcher whose understanding of grief was transformed by a devastating experience in her own life. The surprisingly powerful technique she learned to cope with tragedy, this week on Hidden Brain.
任何经历过丧亲之痛的人都会知道，人们会向你谈论这些阶段，他们期望你经历这些阶段，而我很快对它们感到沮丧，因为我不想别人告诉我会感受到什么。我迫切地想知道我能做些什么，来帮助我们所有人适应这种可怕的损失。今天，我们为您讲述一位研究人员的故事，她对悲伤的理解被自己生活中的一场毁灭性经历彻底改变了。她学会了用惊人强大的技巧来应对悲剧，本周的《隐藏的大脑》。
Lucy Hone is a researcher at the University of Canibary in New Zealand. In 2010, she was living near Christchurch when it was struck by a powerful earthquake. The disaster and a series of aftershocks killed 185 people and destroyed most of downtown Christchurch. Thousands of people lost their homes. Lucy had just returned from graduate school in the United States. She was about to embark on a PhD. Her area of study, resilience. Given the disaster around folding around her, Lucy rolled up her sleeves
露西·霍恩是新西兰坎特伯雷大学的研究员。2010年，她住在基督城附近，当时该市遭遇了一场强烈的地震。这场灾难和一系列余震夺去了185人的生命，并摧毁了基督城市中心的大部分地区。成千上万的人失去了家园。露西刚刚从美国的研究生院毕业。她正准备攻读博士学位。她的研究领域是：韧性。鉴于周围发生的灾难，露西卷起袖子，
and started applying what she had already learned to help the people around her. One day, during a powerful aftershock, Lucy was standing outside her home, which was perched on the cliffs overlooking the city. And I just stood there looking down on our village, and I could see the children's school there. And I could see them all lining up, obviously, being looked after and counted. But what was so awful for me was that I could also see the cliffs on the other side of the village really close to them, you know,
开始运用她已经学到的知识来帮助周围的人。一天，在一次强烈的余震中，露西站在她位于俯瞰城市的悬崖边的家外面。我当时就站在那里，俯瞰着我们的村庄，我能看到那里的儿童学校。我能看到他们都在排队，显然被照顾着并清点着人数。但对我和可怕的是，我还看到村子另一侧离他们非常近的悬崖，你知道的，
like less than a mile away from them tumbling down in front of them. So it was a pretty scary moment in my life. The Christchurch earthquakes lasted for more than a year. The Christchurch earthquakes lasted for more than a year. Residents lived in a constant state of anxiety, not knowing when the next tremor would strike. At one point, Lucy was giving a talk on resilience to survivors when a woman in the audience raised her hand and described a problem she was having. She just said to me, I'm startling all the time. I just am so jumpy every time someone crashes a sorspin lid. I seem to kind of jump in the air and my heart is pounding. And you know, what
比如离他们不到一英里远的地方就在他们面前崩塌。所以那是我生命中一个相当可怕的时刻。基督城地震持续了一年多。基督城市地震持续了一年多。居民们生活在持续的焦虑状态中，不知道下一次地震什么时候会袭来。有一次，露西正在向幸存者发表关于韧性的演讲，听众席中的一位女士举起手，描述了她遇到的一个问题。她只是对我说，我一直在受惊吓。每当有人打碎平底锅盖时，我都感到非常神经质。我似乎会不由自主地跳起来，心跳加速。你知道的，
do I do about that? And I said, firstly, does anyone else feel like that? And the whole room lifted up their hand. So I think it was, you know, a real moment of collective resonance where we all realized that we had exactly the same startle reaction from those ever present earthquakes. You just never knew whether you were safe and you never knew when the next one was going to come. So that kind of hyper vigilance was pretty omnipresent. The problem was, some of this hyper-vigilance, it was totally justified.
我该怎么做？我说：“首先，还有其他人有这种感觉吗？”整个房间的人都举起了手。所以我觉得，这是一个真正产生集体共鸣的时刻，我们都意识到，对于那些无处不在的地震，我们都有着完全相同的惊吓反应。你永远不知道自己是否安全，也永远不知道下一次地震什么时候会来。因此，那种高度警惕的状态可以说是无处不在的。问题是，其中一些高度警惕是完全合乎逻辑的。
Because we had 10,000 over 10,000 aftershocks and 5 or 6 really major events. One of those was on Boxing Day and I'd taken my two sons and a friend visiting from England over to one of the big malls to the Boxing Day sales. And we were all just sitting there afterwards, having something to eat in one of the cafes. And suddenly the whole mall started shaking and so we got under the tables and you know all the cups of tea was being knocked over. But it really terrified us and I remember locking eyes with my eldest son and it was probably that was probably the moment that we realised that these earthquakes weren't
因为我们经历了一万多次余震，还有五六次真正重大的地震。其中一次发生在节礼日，我带着两个儿子和一位从英国来访的朋友去了其中一个大型购物中心血拼节礼日的促销活动。之后我们都坐在那里，在其中一家咖啡馆吃东西。突然整个商场开始摇晃，于是我们躲到桌子底下，你知道所有的茶杯都被撞翻了。但这真的吓坏了我们，我记得和我的大儿子目光交汇，那可能就是那一刻，我们意识到这些地震是
going to go away that actually we were probably now in forward a couple of years. In the summer of 2014, this is a couple of years after the earthquakes. I think you're still working on your PhD at this point. You organized a family beach vacation. It was several hours from your home and you were planning to go with two other families. You and your husband and two teenage sons drove together, I understand your daughter Abby went with another family. Yes, that's right. So my friend Sally and I had arranged a family, you know, get away on a long weekend in June. And at the last minute, Sally's daughter Ella, who was the same age as Abby, just 12 years old at the time, phoned up to say, hey, can Abby come with us in the car? You know, they were great girlfriends and always together. So we thought nothing of it and said, yeah, absolutely, you hop in with her and we dropped Abby off and
不会消失的，实际上我们可能现在……时间快进几年。在2014年的夏天，这是地震发生几年后。我想你当时还在攻读博士学位。你组织了一场家庭海滩度假。距离你的家有好几个小时的车程，你计划和其他两个家庭一起去。你和你的丈夫还有两个十几岁的儿子一起开车前往，我听说你的女儿艾比和另一个家庭一起去了。是的，没错。所以我的朋友莎莉和我安排了一次家庭，你知道的，在六月份的一个长周末去度假。然后在最后一分钟，莎莉的女儿埃拉——她和艾比同龄，当时只有12岁——打电话来说：“嘿，艾比能跟我们一辆车吗？”你知道，她们是很好的闺蜜，总是在一起。所以我们没多想就说：“好啊，当然可以，你跟她一起上车吧。”我们把艾比放下后，
went on our way and we had a sort of four-hour journey ahead of us. And they didn't turn up, you know, later when they should have done, but we didn't really think anything of it at the time. Lucy and her family went to a local restaurant and sat down to dinner. Abby still hadn't arrived, but they were not too worried. The family Abby was travelling with had probably just gotten stuck in traffic. And so we just carried on having dinner without them. And then the hotel owner came and said
便踏上了旅程，我们大概还有四个小时的车程要走。后来他们没有按时出现，但我们当时并没有把这当回事。露西和她的家人去了一家当地的餐厅坐下来吃晚餐。艾比还没到，但他们并不是很担心。艾比随行的那个家庭可能只是遇到了交通堵塞。于是我们继续没有他们一起吃晚餐。然后酒店老板走过来对我们说，
to us, there's a policeman on the phone for you and he'd like to speak to one of you. When Lucy's husband Trevor got on the phone, the police officer didn't say why he wanted to talk. He only said he needed to drive out to meet them. I think he said there's been an accident and I need to come out and talk with you in person. That was the defining moment. That was the moment when I remember Trevor looking across at me and saying,
有一个警察在电话里找你，他想和你们中的一个人通话。当露西的丈夫特雷弗接起电话时，警官并没有说他为什么想谈话。他只说他需要开车出来见他们。我想他说过有一起事故，我需要亲自出来和你们谈谈。那是具有决定性意义的时刻。那是那一刻，我记得特雷弗看着我说，
he's coming to see us and he wouldn't say any more, but they don't bring you good news, do they? And so we hunkered down in the lodges office with the manager who we did kind of know through other families who knew her. And so that was reasonably comfortable being with her. But actually the whole experience, of course, was anything but comfortable. And I remember pacing the room. And possibly it was about a 20 minute wait. You know, he'd come from the local police station that just isn't very local.
他要来见我们，而且他没有多说什么，但他们带给你的绝不会是好消息，对吧？于是我们躲进了旅馆经理的办公室里，我们确实通过其他认识她的家庭认识她。所以和她在一起感觉比较舒服。但实际上，整个经历当然一点也不舒服。我记得在房间里踱步。可能大约等了20分钟。你知道，他是从当地警察局赶过来的，那个警察局其实不太近。
So we had an agonizing weight. When the police officer finally arrived, he had an odd question about Abbey Shoe's. He asked me what she was wearing and probably like any mother. I knew exactly what my dear daughter was wearing and so I told him. Abby was wearing black converse chucktailer height ups. And he said to me, in that case, I'm sorry to tell you that your daughter, that was your daughter in the accident, and, you know, I'm tragically have to tell you that she has died. And he also told us that Sally, my friend, had been killed and Sally's beautiful daughter Ella,
所以我们经历了一场痛苦的等待。当这位警察终于到达时，他问了一个关于艾比鞋子的奇怪问题。他问我她穿的是什么鞋，可能像任何一位母亲一样，我清楚地知道我亲爱的女儿穿着什么，所以我告诉了他。艾比穿着黑色的匡威Chuck Taylor高帮帆布鞋。他对我说：“如果是这样，我很遗憾地告诉你，那是你的女儿在事故中，而且，你知道，我不得不悲痛地告诉你，她已经去世了。”他还告诉我们，我的朋友莎莉遇难了，莎莉美丽的女儿埃拉——
who was such dear friends with our Abbey, had also died. So all three of them had been hit by a car who drove through a stop sign and plowed into them. It's hard to even imagine what you were going through who drove through a stop sign and plowed into them. It's hard to even imagine what you were going through at this point, Lucy. This is literally every parent's worst nightmare, but this nightmare was actually happening to you.
她是我们艾比那么亲密的朋友——也去世了。所以他们三个人都被一辆闯过停车标志并猛烈撞击他们的汽车撞倒了。很难想象你当时经历了什么，她被一辆闯过停车标志并猛烈撞击他们的汽车撞倒了。露西，很难想象你当时经历了什么。这简直是每一位父母最大的噩梦，但这个噩梦却实实在在地发生在了你身上。
Did you have a sense of being able to process what was going on, were you in shock? I was definitely in shock. I think it is a bit of an outer body experience. You can almost observe yourself going through the process. I remember the physical sensations of feeling sick and sweating and having a droid drank so much water.
你当时有没有觉得自己能够处理正在发生的事情？你是不是处于休克状态？我确实处于休克状态。我认为这有点像灵魂出窍的体验。你几乎可以观察自己经历这个过程。我记得那种生病、出汗、喝了那么多水的身体感觉。
I remember that. And I remember pacing. couldn't stay anywhere, you know, I remember getting on the floor, getting up, walking around, I just, you know, you don't know what to do in that moment. I remember calling my sister and not being able to get through to her and then calling every member of her family in it turned out they were all together in a bar and they suddenly realized that something awful would happen because they'd all had these missed calls. And I remember the other people in the lodge and kind of feeling sorry for them thinking oh this is such an awful thing for you to watch. So you have kind of odd, I think, odd thoughts. But actually what I remember
我记得那些。我还记得自己在踱步。你哪里也呆不住，你知道，我记得一会儿趴在地板上，一会儿站起来，四处走动，我只是，你知道，那一刻你不知道该怎么办。我记得给我姐姐打电话，却打不通，然后给她家里的每个人打电话，结果发现他们全都在一个酒吧里，他们突然意识到发生了可怕的事情，因为他们都看到了这些未接来电。我还记得旅馆里的其他人，心里甚至有点替他们感到难过，心想：“噢，看着这种事对你们来说太可怕了。”所以你会有一些奇怪的想法，我想，一些奇怪的想法。但实际上，我最记忆犹新的，
Shankar most of all is this feeling that that was our new life story and that her death would be part of our life story for, you know, the remainder of our days. or the remainder of our days. That night, the police drove Lucy and her family to a hospital in Christchurch, where we then met my sister and her family, which was just a terrible moment. You can imagine family collective grief. And we were asked to go and identify the body and my dear son Patti went, said to
尚卡尔，是那种感觉：那是我们全新的生活故事，她的死将成为我们生活故事的一部分，贯穿我们余下的日子。或者说我们余下的日子。那天晚上，警察开车送露西和她的家人去了基督城的一家医院，我们在那里遇到了我姐姐和她的家人，那真是一个可怕的时刻。你可以想象那种集体家庭悲哀。我们被要求去认尸，我亲爱的儿子帕蒂对
his dad, come on dad, we've got to go and do it, just awful moments. We went home at 5 or 6am and all just walked back into the house and sat there in disbelief. I do remember in those first hours and days to be honest, feeling like I was on autopilot and that people were kind of moving me around, standing behind me, kind of pointing my shoulders in the direction I had to go. You know, it was just staggering really numb. And you just, in disbelief, I think that is the thing, isn't it, that when it comes out of the blue, your world has been smashed apart. Nothing makes sense, and you're just struggling and grappling to get through each hour.
他爸爸说：“走吧，爸爸，我们得去面对现实。”那真是可怕的时刻。我们在凌晨5点或6点回到家，所有人默默走回屋里，难以置信地坐在那里。我确实记得在最初的几个小时和几天里，老实说，我感觉自己像是在自动驾驶，人们在某种程度上推着我四处走动，站在我身后，把我的肩膀扶向我必须前进的方向。你知道，那种感觉真的是震惊到麻木。你简直无法置信，我想就是那种感觉，当灾难突如其来时，你的世界被粉碎了。一切都失去了意义，你只是在挣扎着度过每一个小时。
And I honestly, I remember there's awful grief, sweats, and not sleeping, sleep, it was just, it was awful. I understand that at one point soon after Abbi's death, a couple of grief counselors came to your home. Do you remember what they told you? I do. We had a few people come and give us well-meaning advice. And really what I've got stands out for me is that I remember them saying to me, you're going to need to write five years of your life off to this grief. You
老实说，我记得那种可怕的悲伤冷汗，还有无法入睡，睡眠问题，简直太糟糕了。我听说在艾比去世后不久的某个时候，有两位悲伤辅导员来到了你的家里。你还记得他们对你说了什么吗？我记得。有几个人来给我们提供好意的建议。实际上令我印象深刻的是，我记得他们对我说：“你们需要为这种悲伤写下五年的空白期。”
know, you're really not going to be able to function for the next five years. And that we were now prime candidates for divorce, family estrangement, and mental illness. And honestly, I remember thinking, wow, you know, I thought my life was already truly terrible. I can't believe that people are kind of dumping all this on us as well. And I was horrified. I remember someone talking to me about the fact that they'd lost a brother who had died
你知道，在接下来的五年里，你们真的无法正常生活。并且我们现在是离婚、家庭疏远和精神疾病的头号候选人。老实说，我记得当时想：“哇，你知道的，我以为我的生活已经够悲惨了。我简直不敢相信人们还要把所有这些也强加给我们。”我感到惊恐万状。我记得有人跟我谈起过他们失去了一个兄弟，那个兄弟去世了，
and then he said, to be honest, I don't really speak to my other brother any longer, you know, his death tore our family apart. And I remember thinking, okay, right, that's something else I'm going to have to watch out for. The friends and counsellors obviously meant well. But after they left, Lucy felt worse. It wasn't just that they were telling her that her life was terrible. They also seemed to be telling her that there was nothing she could do about it. When we come back, Lucy started to wonder if that was true.
然后他说：“说实话，我现在不再跟我另一个兄弟说话了，你知道的，他的死让我们的家庭分崩离析。”我当时想：“好吧，明白了，这是另一件我必须小心的事。”这些朋友和辅导员显然是出于好意。但他们离开后，露西感觉更糟糕了。这不仅是因为他们告诉她生活很糟糕，还因为他们似乎在告诉她，她对此无能为力。当我们回来时，露西开始怀疑这是真的吗？
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Lucy Hone is a public health researcher at the University of Canabary in New Zealand. She studies resilience. In the summer of 2014, Lucy experienced every parent's greatest nightmare. Her 12-year-old daughter was killed in a car crash. Before the accident, Lucy had been helping survivors of the Christchurch earthquakes. Suddenly, she needed help herself. Lucy, you've described a moment soon after the accident when you found yourself standing in your bedroom, asking yourself a question. And the question was, can I go on? Can you describe that moment
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。露西·霍恩是新西兰坎特伯雷大学的公共卫生研究员。她研究韧性。在2014年夏天，露西经历了每一位父母最大的噩梦。她12岁的女儿在一场车祸中丧生。在事故发生前，露西一直在帮助基督城地震的幸存者。突然之间，她自己也需要帮助了。露西，你曾描述过事故发生后不久的一个时刻，当时你发现自己站在卧室里，问了自己一个问题。这个问题是：我能坚持下去吗？你能描述一下那个时刻吗？
to me? Yes, it was my darkest bleakest moment, I think, where I did have a sense that it all felt just too hard. Every day, it felt like we were climbing a mountain. Instead of ever, we never got to the top. Every day, you'd be put down to the bottom and have to start the whole thing again. It was exhausting and I lost hope and I'm a pretty hopeful person and so I think that is a moment that really stands out for me. So something that many people don't realize is that grief isn't just in the mind as you
是的，那是我最黑暗、最凄凉的时刻，我想，当时我确实有一种一切都太难了的感觉。每天，我们都觉得像是在爬山。而且我们永远到不了山顶。每天你都会被扔回山底，然后不得不重新开始这一切。这太让人筋疲力尽了，我失去了希望，而我其实是一个挺有希望的人，所以我想那是真正让我印象深刻的时刻。所以很多人没有意识到的一件事是，悲伤不仅仅发生在脑海里，正如你所说，它在身体上也让人筋疲力尽。
say it's physically exhausting. It certainly is, honestly, physically exhausting. I did a lot of sleeping. And of course, sleep gives you a temporary break as well from the thinking, because it is dust goes round and round in your head. And I was lucky that I could sleep and that our boys were of an age where I could,
确实如此，老实说，体力上筋疲力尽。我睡了很多觉。当然，睡眠也让你暂时从思考中解脱出来，因为那些想法一直在你的脑海里转来转去。我很幸运，我能入睡，而且我们的男孩们也到了这样一个年纪：如果这一切实在难以承受，我可以
you know, go to bed at any time of day if it was all too much. And I knew because of my training, you know, the importance of sleep as well. I understand that you had conversations at this time with your husband where you were running through what if scenarios regarding Abby. Do you remember what they were about Lucy? We once sat down on the rocks we lived by the beach and we sat there and yes having those kind of what if we hadn't arranged that we can go away and what if you know we hadn't let her in the car but then we also said to each other, she didn't suffer, we didn't have to sit
你知道的，在一天中的任何时间去睡觉。因为我的专业背景，我也深知睡眠的重要性。我听说你在这个时候曾和你的丈夫进行过对话，你们在对话中反复假设关于艾比的“如果”情境。露西，你还记得它们是关于什么的吗？有一次我们坐在我们海滩住所附近的岩石上，坐在那里，是的，谈论着那些“如果我们没有安排那次外出该怎么办”以及“如果我们没有让她上车该怎么办”之类的情境。但随后我们也对彼此说，她没有遭受痛苦，我们不必像许多父母那样守在她的病床边数周数月，看着生命从她身上流逝。我们从她瞬间离世、不知道发生了什么中得到了一点安慰。所以我们，是的，从某种意义上说，她瞬间离世，甚至不知道发生了什么。所以我们，是的，从某种意义上说，
like so many parents at her bedside for weeks and months and watch the live train out of her. We took some comfort from the fact that she died instantly and wouldn't have known what was happening to her. And so we were, yeah, in that sense, she died instantly and wouldn't have known what was happening to her. And so we were, yeah, in that sense, we were just trying to help each other focus on the bits that weren't so terrible. At the same time, I think this is really revealing about people's grief journeys in general, which is that very often when grief strikes a family,
我们只是试图互相帮助，把注意力集中在那些没那么糟糕的部分上。与此同时，我认为这深刻揭示了人们总的悲伤历程，那就是当悲伤降临到一个家庭时，
the people whom you would normally turn to for help are also suffering. And that can really make it difficult to find your way out because everyone around you is also being weighed down by this thing. Well, it's so true, Shankar, and everybody grieves differently, you know? And my mother had died when I was 30 and Trevor lost his father when he was 12, so we had both experienced grief before. But we were very aware that we have two, 14 and 15-year-old beautiful boys who were obviously processing it in a different way to their parents. And then we had all Abby's friends. We live in a small family community and so we had all of them. And we weren't just one family, but two families. And so there was a real
你通常会向其寻求帮助的人也在遭受痛苦。这真的会让人很难找到出路，因为你身边的每个人也都在被这件事压得喘不过气来。哦，确实如此，尚卡尔，每个人悲伤的方式都不同，你知道吗？我妈妈在我30岁时去世了，特雷弗在12岁时失去了父亲，所以我们以前都经历过悲伤。但我们非常清楚，我们有两个14岁和15岁可爱的男孩，他们显然在以不同于他们父母的方式消化这件事。然后我们还有艾比所有的朋友。我们生活在一个小型的家庭社区里，所以我们拥有他们所有人。我们不仅仅是一个家庭，而是两个家庭。所以有一种真实的集体悲伤感。
sense of collective grief. You know, they lost two girls from the local primary and one of the mums. And particularly so soon after the earthquakes. You say that grief had a way of sneaking up on you. You you call these grief ambushes. What do you mean by that term? is that you just can't control the emotions. And in the least likely moments, they seem to absolutely take hold of you. And so whether it was sitting at the traffic lights or once I write about how I went to the supermarket, which because it had fallen down in the earthquakes, we didn't have a local supermarket for sometime,
你知道的，他们失去了当地小学的两个女孩和一个母亲。尤其是在地震发生后不久。你说悲伤有一种会悄悄靠近你的方式。你称这些为“悲伤伏击”。你这个词是什么意思？意思是说你根本无法控制情绪。在最意想不到的时刻，它们似乎完全掌控了你。所以无论是坐在红绿灯前，还是有一次我写到我去超市——因为超市在地震中倒塌了，我们有很长一段时间没有当地的超市，
five or six years. So it wasn't until after Abbey died that they reopened the local supermarket. And I swam in there thinking fabulous. It's back, you know, how good is this? And I just got to the aisle that had her favorite snacks in it. And just stood there and dissolved. And it just took me back to so many times when her little kindergarten was across the road and we'd come there after Kendi and you know and she'd buy her favorite bits and we were always together and I just stood there and thought oh seriously this is literally
五六年之久。所以直到艾比死后，他们才重新开业了当地的超市。我兴高采烈地走进去，心想太棒了。它回来了，你知道的，这有多好？我刚走到放着她最喜欢的小食品的货道上，就站在那里崩溃了。这让我想起了无数次她的那个小幼儿园就在马路对面，我们上完课后来到这里，你知道的，她会买她最喜欢的零食，我们总是在一起。我站在那里想，哦，说真的，这简直就是
that kind of grief ambush that overwhelms you and we're almost powerless to do anything about it. And it was okay for me because I was in a quiet supermarket aisle at the time, but when it happens at work, that's just, it's a really tough, challenging aspect of grief. So the grief counselor is another's to all you, that the next five years of your life are going to be consumed by grief, that you were, you know, prime candidates for divorce and a strangement mental illness. You also heard about the five stages of grief. What was the conventional wisdom of those five stages. Like most people I could probably name three of them, but when people started telling me about them and boy anyone who's ever been bereaved will know that people tell you about them. They expect you to go through them and pretty quickly I became frustrated with them because I didn't feel anger and animosity towards the driver.
那种让你不知所措的“悲伤伏击”，而我们几乎无能为力。对我来说还好，因为当时我在一个安静的超市货道里，但当它发生在工作场所时，那真的、那真是悲伤中一个非常艰难、极具挑战性的方面。所以悲伤辅导员和其他人告诉你，你生命的接下来的五年将被悲伤吞噬，你，你知道的，是离婚、家庭疏远和精神疾病的头号候选人。你也听说过悲伤的五个阶段。那些五个阶段的传统观点是什么？像大多数人一样，我大概能说出其中三个，但当人们开始向我讲述它们时——天哪，任何经历过丧亲之痛的人都知道人们会向你讲述它们。他们期望你经历它们——我很快就对它们感到沮丧，因为我对司机没有感到愤怒和敌意。
I knew that that was a terrible mistake, but he didn't do it intentionally. And I wasn't in denial, you know, from the very first moment, as I've said, I remember thinking, okay, this is my job now, you know, my mission is to survive this. And so they didn't kind of fit with my experience, but the other aspect that quickly frustrated me about the five stages is that I just found them too passive. You know, it's reasonably helpful to be told that these, you might feel, you know, depression and acceptance or anger and denial and all of these different things. But actually, it was like, I don't want to be told what I'm going to feel. I am desperate to know what I can do to help us all adapt to this terrible loss.
我知道那是一个可怕的错误，但他不是故意的。我也没有否认，你知道，从第一刻起，正如我所说，我记得当时想：“好吧，这就是我现在的任务，你知道，我的使命是熬过这一切。”所以它们不太符合我的经历，但让我对这五个阶段感到沮丧的另一个方面是，我发现它们太被动了。你知道，听到你可能会感到抑郁、接受、愤怒、否认以及所有这些不同的事情，这在一定程度上是有帮助的。但事实上，这种感觉就像是：我不想别人告诉我我会感受到什么。我迫切地想知道我能做些什么，来帮助我们所有人适应这种可怕的损失。
I'm struck by the fact that at a certain point in your in your journey of grief over Abby's death, you were thinking like a researcher or starting to ask yourself whether you yourself could be an almost a research subject that you're studying yourself, you're observing yourself, you're thinking of your own experience, not just as a person going through the experience, but like a scientist. Did you have a moment of epiphany when you realized in some ways that you could become your own research subject on this topic? I think I did, I think it's fair to say that yes, was kind of an epiphany aha moment. And it is also, you know, who I am. I am a researcher and I'm a mum and a wife.
我印象深刻的是，在您经历艾比去世的悲伤旅程的某个阶段，您的思考方式就像一名研究人员，或者开始问自己，您自己是否可以几乎成为一个研究对象——你在研究自己，在观察自己，你不仅在以一个亲历者的身份思考自己的经历，更像是一个科学家。当你意识到在某些方面你可以成为这个话题的研究对象时，你是否有过顿悟的时刻？我想我是有的，我觉得可以这样说，那确实是一个顿悟的“啊哈”时刻。这也是，你知道的，我是谁。我是一名研究人员，同时我也是一位母亲和妻子。
And so you're always, we all wear multiple hats, don't we? It's just that mine happened to be that I was experiencing this ever-stating loss and curious about my experiences simultaneously. And that was the kind of ah-ha moment that I was doing this internally kind of observing my loss and my reaction to it. And then I thought, well, what I'm really curious about is we have all these tools from resilience psychology, which have been shown to help people cope with potentially traumatic events.
所以你总是，我们都扮演着多重角色，不是吗？只是碰巧我的角色是，我正在经历这个毁灭性的损失，同时又对自己的经历感到好奇。这就是那种“啊哈”时刻，我在内部进行这种观察，观察我的损失以及我对它的反应。然后我想，好吧，我真正好奇的是，我们拥有来自韧性心理学的各种工具，这些工具已被证明可以帮助人们应对潜在的创伤性事件。
Well, how useful are they when they are brought to the context of bereavement? And so that's been the question that I've been really exploring ever since Abbey died. Pondering this question gave her the space to analyze how her own mind was responding to grief. When she noticed something about how she was coping, she reserved judgment about what it meant. When she engaged in what if scenarios, what if she hadn't allowed Abby to drive with the other family, what if she hadn't planned a beach vacation.
那么，当它们被引入丧亲之痛的背景时，它们有多大用处呢？所以这就是自从艾比去世以来我一直在真正探讨的问题。思考这个问题为她提供了空间，来分析她自己的大脑是如何对悲伤做出反应的。当她注意到自己如何应对时，她对这意味着什么保留了判断。当她参与“如果”情境时——如果她没有允许艾比和其他家庭一起开车离开会怎样，如果她没有计划海滩度假会怎样——
She noticed how these thoughts made her feel. She paid attention to how she felt after getting exercise or a good night's sleep. In other words, she started behaving like a scientist. She eventually discovered there were things that made her feel better and things that made her feel worse. She came up with a series of techniques that gave her a measure of control over her grief. I distinctly remember standing in the kitchen at the Cocoa one day thinking, seriously Lucy, choose life, not death, don't lose what you have to what you have lost. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
她注意到这些想法让她感觉如何。她注意到了自己在锻炼或睡了个好觉之后的感受。换句话说，她开始像个科学家一样行事。她最终发现有些事情让她感觉好一些，有些事情让她感觉更糟。她想出了一系列技巧，使她能够在一定程度上控制自己的悲伤。我清楚地记得有一天站在可可村的厨房里心想：“说真的，露西，选择生活，而不是死亡，不要因为你所失去的而失去你所拥有的。”您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Lucy Hohn is a public health researcher at the University of Canterbury. After her 12-year-old daughter was killed in a traffic crash, Lucy tracked her own bereavement process closely. She realized that she herself did not follow the five stages of grief. She also realized that we are wrong when we think grief is only something that happens to us. While it's true that grieving people do not feel they have much control over their emotions,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。露西·霍恩是坎特伯雷大学的公共卫生研究员。在她12岁的女儿在一场车祸中丧生后，露西密切追踪了自己的丧亲过程。她意识到自己并没有经历悲伤的五个阶段。她还意识到，当我们认为悲伤只是降临在我们身上的事情时，我们错了处。虽然悲伤的人确实觉得他们对自己情绪的控制力不大，
there were things she could do to change the way she felt. They were active choices she could make. These choices did not erase her grief, but they did allow her to feel like she could manage it. The first step was to realize there was a difference between her reaction to grief and her response to it. Yes, so your grief reaction, you have very little control over, and that is all those physical symptoms that occur when we are bereaved. And for me, that was that aching right in my solar plexus and that the grief sweats, those awful nighttime sweats, and then the tor roller coaster of emotion. So it's
但她确实可以做一些事情来改变自己的感受。她可以做出积极的选择。这些选择并没有抹去她的悲伤，但它们确实让她觉得自己能够掌控悲伤。第一步是认识到她对悲伤的反应（reaction）和她对悲伤的应对（response）之间是有区别的。是的，对于你的悲伤反应，你的控制力非常小，那都是当我们经历丧亲之痛时发生的各种生理症状。对我来说，那是我太阳神经丛深处的隐痛、悲伤带来的冷汗、那些可怕的夜间盗汗，然后是情绪的过山车。所以
really hard to control those and we call that grief reaction, but we do also have the grief response which is about how we choose to respond to the grief and that is about the ways of thinking and acting and the micro choices we make all day long, which can really help our harm our grief. And so, you know, while grief reaction, we have little control, grief response is pervaded with choice.
很难控制这些，我们称之为悲伤反应，但我们确实也有悲伤应对，这关乎我们如何选择应对悲伤，这关乎全天候做出的思维和行动方式以及微小的选择，这些选择真的可以帮助或损害我们的悲伤。所以，你知道的，虽然对于悲伤反应，我们控制力很小，但悲伤应对则充满了选择。
As Lucy started to analyse her own grief like a scientist, she stumbled on the work of Columbia University researcher George Bonanna. Well, certainly George Bonanna's work is really comforting and what he discovered was that actually most people get through grief on their own without needing any kind of medication or clinical intervention. And so this kind of really gave me hope and the other great researchers in this field are Straub and Schut, whose oscillation theory I came across, which is a different kind of model of grief that says that we need to approach our grief and then it's OK to withdraw and take a break from grief. And that's not avoidance and denial, but actually a really healthy way to grieve.
当露西像科学家一样开始分析自己的悲伤时，她偶然发现了哥伦比亚大学研究员乔治·博南纳的工作。嗯，当然，乔治·博南纳的工作真的非常令人宽慰，他发现实际上大多数人都能靠自己度过悲伤，而不需要任何药物或临床干预。所以这给了一大批人希望，而这个领域的其他伟大研究员是施特劳布和舒特，我遇到了他们的振荡理论，这是一种不同类型的悲伤模型，它表明我们需要面对悲伤，然后也可以从悲伤中抽离出来并休息一下。这并不是逃避和否认，而实际上是一种非常健康的悲伤方式。
You're talking about the researchers Margaret, Struber and Hank should describe for me again what they meant by the storm oscillation because you found both yourself going through this, but also in some ways deciding to sort of pursue this yourself. Yes, I think it made sense to me. So their theory of oscillation is that we oscillate between approaching our grief and then taking a break from it, but we also oscillate between attending to these two different types of grief. One is loss oriented and the other is restoration oriented, meaning that you kind of fluctuate between coping with the loss, the actual for me, you know,
你谈到了研究人员玛格丽特·施特伯和汉克·舒特，请再为我描述一下他们所说的“悲伤振荡”是什么意思，因为你发现自己既在经历这个过程，同时也在某种程度上决定自己去追寻这一点。是的，我觉得这对我很有意义。所以他们的振荡理论是，我们在走近悲伤和从悲伤中抽离休息之间振荡，但我们在关注这两种不同类型的悲伤之间也会振荡。一种是以失去为导向的，另一种是以恢复为导向的，这意味着你会在应对失去之间摇摆不定——对我而言，实际上面对的是，
Abbey and how much I missed her. And then the restoration bit is about, and who am I now and how will I learn to live without her and her place in the family and how am I going to get back to work and go to the supermarket and face my friends. So you kind of ebb and flow between these two processes and it's a real kind of dynamic process. What resonated for me was that we needed to take breaks from our grieving process and actually that's where positive emotion can come into. When Lucy first confronted Abby's death, grief felt like an impossible mountain looming before her. When she was told she was a prime candidate for divorce or mental illness, that mountain grew larger. But when she started looking at the scientific evidence, she discovered cause for hope.
艾比以及我多么想念她。而恢复的部分则是关于：现在的我是谁？我将如何学会没有她的生活，她在家庭中的地位是什么？我将如何重返工作岗位、去超市并面对我的朋友？所以你在这两个过程之间起伏跌宕，这是一种非常动态的过程。对我产生共鸣的是，我们需要从悲伤的过程中抽离休息，而实际上，正是在那里，积极的情绪才能产生。当露西第一次面对艾比的死时，悲伤就像一座耸立在她面前无法逾越的高山。当有人告诉她她是离婚或精神疾病的头号候选人时，那座山变得更大了。但当她开始查看科学证据时，她发现了带来希望的理由。
While a small minority of people do get stuck in grief, the majority recover and regain healthy levels of psychological functioning. When Lucy chose to spend time away from her grief, this wasn't denial. Her brain was doing the perfectly healthy thing of oscillating between attending to grief and attending to recovery. Lucy also arrived at a third insight. I know from resilience psychology that it's really important to choose where you focus your attention. And so I absolutely had this voice in my head that would be aware if I was bargaining, if I started to do that, what if I hadn't booked that weekend the way, what if we had just left, they just left ten minutes later that day.
虽然一小部分人确实会陷入悲伤中无法自拔，但大多数人都能恢复并重新获得健康的心理功能水平。当露西选择花时间远离悲伤时，这并不是否认。她的大脑在做一件完全健康的事情：在关注悲伤和关注恢复之间摇摆。露西还得到了第三个洞察。我从韧性心理学中得知，选择将注意力集中在哪里非常重要。所以我的脑海里绝对有这样一个声音，它会意识到我是否在讨价还价，如果我开始这样做的话——如果我们没有预订那个周末的外出该怎么办，如果我们只是离开……如果他们那天晚走十分钟该怎么办。
And then I'd think to myself, you're only allowed to have two wottiffs. So once I'd done one, you know, what if we hadn't booked? I actually, I booked the holiday the weekend away. So what if I hadn't booked it? And what if we hadn't allowed her into the car that day? And then I'd go to do another one and I'd think, nope, that's your limit. Go and distract yourself because any more what ifs are going to be harming you and you need to
然后我会对自己说：“你只被允许有两次‘如果’。”所以一旦我想过一次，你知道的，“如果我们没有预订呢？”其实，我预订了那个周末的度假。那么“如果我们没有预订它呢？”还有“如果我们那天没有让她上车呢？”然后当我准备进行第三次时，我会想：“不，这就是你的极限。去转移注意力吧，因为再多的‘如果’只会伤害你，你需要
survive this. And so I would distract myself by phoning somebody else or doing something that really demanded my attention. This was part of a larger idea borrowed from cognitive behavioral therapy. As thoughts went through her mind, she started to ask herself a simple question, is this thought good for me or bad for me? An important fork in the road came when Lucy and her husband were asked to attend the trial of the driver who had run the stop sign and T-bone the car in which Abby was riding Lucy asked herself
活下来。”所以我会通过给别人打电话或做一些真正需要我注意力的事情来转移注意力。这是从认知行为疗法中借用的一個更大理念的一部分。当各种想法掠过她的脑海时，她开始问自己一个简单的问题：这个想法对我有益还是有害？一个重要的转折点出现在露西和她的丈夫被要求参加那个闯了停车标志并侧面撞击了艾比所乘汽车的司机的庭审时。露西问自己：
Would going to the trial be good for me or bad for me? grief is full of choices and so when we were invited to go to the trial I And so when we were invited to go to the trial, I used a strategy that encourages you to ask yourself, is doing that, going to help me or harm me in my quest to survive this loss? And so Trevor and I both agreed that we didn't want to go to the trial, that actually that wasn't going to help us. I just didn't need to be standing in the same room as the driver at that time. I needed to focus my energy and attention elsewhere.
去参加庭审对我有益还是有害？悲伤充满了选择，所以当我们被邀请去参加庭审时，我……所以当我们被邀请去参加庭审时，我使用了一种策略，它鼓励你问自己：这样做，在我想方设法熬过这场灾难的求生之路上，是对我有帮助还是有害？所以特雷弗和我一致认为我们不想去参加庭审，事实上那对我们没有任何帮助。我当时根本不需要和那个司机站在同一个房间里。我需要把我的注意力和精力集中在别的地方。
And that was on the boys. So in fact, we went instead to their school, just that day to meet with the teachers and just kind of check in with them because they've just been back at school about three weeks, I think. And that felt like a much better use of my time. And I'm distinctly know that what I appreciate it was that I was kind of putting myself in the driver's seat and taking back a bit of control. So in some ways, I think what I hear you saying is that when people are experiencing grief, partly what we almost expect them to do is we expect them to follow scripts. And sometimes you provide scripts to them and say, here's we almost expect them to do is we expect them to follow scripts. And sometimes we provide scripts to them and say, here's what you're supposed to feel.
那就是放在男孩们身上。所以事实上，我们那天去了他们的学校，去见见老师并了解一下情况，因为我想他们刚回到学校大约三周。这感觉是对我时间更好的利用。我清楚地知道，我所欣赏的是，我把自己放在了驾驶座上，重新夺回了一点控制权。所以在某种程度上，我想我听到你所说的是，当人们经历悲伤时，我们几乎对他们抱有的期望之一就是希望他们遵循剧本。有时你为他们提供剧本，说：“这就是——我们几乎对他们抱有的期望之一就是希望他们遵循剧本。有时我们为他们提供剧本，并对他们说：‘这就是你本该感受到的。’
And here's what comes next. And here's what comes before this. And here's what you're supposed to do after this. And in some ways, by taking back that narrative, you can start to make choices that in some ways craft your own journey. And it may be that the choice that you make is different than the choice that your husband makes. journey and it may be that the choice that you make is different than the choice that your husband makes, but it's important that each of you exercises the agency to make the choice that in some ways is the best fit for your mental makeup and your psychological well-being.
这就是接下来要发生的。这就是在这之前发生的。这就是你在这之后应该做的。’在某种程度上，通过夺回叙事权，你可以开始做出选择，在某种程度上塑造你自己的旅程。你做出的选择可能和你丈夫做出的选择不同，但重要的是，你们每个人都行使自主权，做出最适合你心理结构和心理健康的抉择。
Yeah, that's completely it. We all grieve differently. Grief is as individual as your fingerprint. There's actually very little evidence that says that we go through those five stages, they have been perpetuated because they're a tidy model and health practitioners and people like to, they are drawn to the fact that when people are grieving and it's such a torrid time, that if they can just give them a tidy five stage model, then maybe that, you know, makes them feel better and it's easier for the health practitioners to kind of give this model. But actually, it's not like that. It's messy and untidy. And in our work, people rarely say that they go through those stages. I'm wondering if there were other choices you found yourself having to make where you
是的，完全是这样。我们每个人悲伤的方式都不同。悲伤就像你的指纹一样独特。实际上，几乎没有证据表明我们一定会经历那五个阶段，它们之所以被延续下来，是因为它们是一个整洁的模型，健康从业者和人们喜欢它们，他们被这样一点吸引：当人们处于悲伤之中、经历如此痛苦的时期时，如果他们能得到一个整洁的五阶段模型，那么也许这，你知道的，能让他们感觉好受一些，而且健康从业者也更容易提供这种模型。但实际上，它并不是那样的。它是混乱而杂乱的。在我们的工作中，人们很少说他们经历过这些阶段。我想知道你是否发现自己不得不做出其他选择
could ask yourself the question, is this going to be good for me or is this going to be bad for me? Absolutely. It became my kind of go-to strategy. And I would, I'd often find myself, of course, you know, I'm weak-willed like everybody. And I'd find myself trawling through Instagram later at night, looking at pictures of Abby and noticing the comments that her friends have put on there and I do that for a few minutes and then think seriously Lucy, you know, is this helping or is it harming you? Be kind to yourself put your phone away and go to bed and I so often did find those things, you know looking at photos
你可以问自己这个问题：这对我有好处还是有坏处？当然可以。这成了我的首选策略。我发现自己当然也会像其他人一样意志薄弱。我发现自己会在深夜刷Instagram，看艾比的照片，并注意到她朋友在上面留下的评论。我会看几分钟，然后认真地想：露西，你知道这到底是在帮你还是在害你？对自己好一点，把手机收起来去睡觉。我经常发现这些事情，你知道的，看照片
And I so often did find those things, you know, looking at photos, even just hanging out with her friends. As I say, we're a pretty small community, so I would bump into her friends. And sometimes that would be good. And other times I'd think, no, that's actually not what you need right now. That's not going to be good for you. So just walk back out of the supermarket and come back later on whatever it was. But it was definitely my kind of practical question that enabled me to find my own pathway through grief.
我经常发现这些事情，你知道的，看照片，甚至只是和她的朋友们在一起。正如我所说，我们是一个相当小的社区，所以我经常会撞见她的朋友。有时这很好。而有时我会想：不，这其实不是你现在需要的。这对你没有好处。所以只要走回超市，晚点再来，无论是什么。但这绝对是我那种能够让我找到自己的悲伤之路的实用问题。
It's worth pointing out that I think that what you did is not easy to do. It really is easy to get angry. It does feel natural to engage in what ifs these are human reactions. And I want to flag that while making conscious choices about what to focus on does make sense, that doesn't mean that it's always easy to do. No, and I would totally agree with that. And I always make that point of saying to people, you know, this isn't easy, but it is possible. And I think it comes down to, for me, my motivation for survival was huge because we had lived
值得指出的是，我认为你所做的事情并不容易做到。生气确实很容易。陷入“如果……会怎样”的想法感觉很自然，这些都是人类的反应。我想指出的是，虽然对关注点做出有意识的选择确实有意义，但这并不意味着这总是容易做到。不，我完全同意这一点。我总是对人们说：这并不容易，但它是可能的。我认为这归根结底在于，对我来说，我生存的动力是巨大的，因为我们经历过
through every parent's worst nightmare, and I felt like the stakes were pretty high, and that almost made that easier to stick to the two what ifs rule, because I felt like if I didn't, the grief could completely consume me. And so that's not saying that I'm in denial because I certainly did grieve and we did, you know, all for experiencing all kinds of emotions and I didn't want to shut them out, but I definitely wanted to find my way and while oowing in things that are beyond my control, was not helpful to me. And as I say, I felt like the fight was on for survival.
经历了每个父母最可怕的噩梦，我觉得赌注相当高，这几乎使得坚持“两个如果”规则变得更容易，因为我觉得如果我不这样做，悲伤可能会彻底吞噬我。所以这并不是说我在否认，因为我确实悲伤过，而且我们确实经历过各种各样的情绪，我不想把它们关在门外，但我绝对想找到自己的路，而沉溺于我无法控制的事情对我没有帮助。正如我所说，我觉得生存之战已经打响。
Lucy thought back to her days as a graduate student studying resilience at the University of Pennsylvania. At one point, her professors worked with the US military to develop a resilience training program for a million soldiers. That program was based on the same underlying idea. Pay attention to where you pay attention. There was very much that kind of cognitive focus that you need to be aware of the way your thoughts and actions are combining and really question whether the ways you are thinking and acting are working for you or working
露西回想起她在宾夕法尼亚大学攻读心理韧性研究研究生的日子。有一段时间，她的教授与美军合作，为一百万士兵开发了一项心理韧性训练项目。该项目基于相同的底层理念。关注你的关注点。那种认知焦点非常重要，你需要意识到你的思想和行动是如何结合的，并真正质疑你的思考和行动方式是否对你有用或对你有害。
against you. And so they did lots of that sort of took positive psychology, this field of being strengths-based and put that into a package so that they could train the drill sergeants who then in turn could train all of the rest of the army. And I love the phrase that they use in this training, which was hunt the good stuff. And I love that idea because you're speaking to your audience in a language they can understand, but it's the same idea that's being preached in cognitive behavioural therapy. Absolutely. So they actually created the hashtag
对你有害。所以他们做了很多这样的事情，吸收了积极心理学这一以优势为基础的领域，并把它打包成一个包裹，以便他们可以训练钻研军士，然后他们反过来可以训练军队的其他所有人。我喜欢他们在这次训练中使用的短语，那就是“寻找美好事物”。我喜欢这个想法，因为你在用你的听众能听懂的语言跟他们交流，但这与认知行为疗法中宣扬的理念是相同的。绝对的。所以他们实际上创建了标签
htgshuntthegoodstuff. And actually somebody after Abidi gave us a poster that said accept the good. And I think these two phrases accept the good and hunt the good stuff. Speak to the fact that language is really important here. That what we're talking about is that we want to encourage people to tune into what is still good in their world despite everything that's happened. But we're also encouraging them to find language that fits with them. So for me, you know, being told to count my blessings or ask to do random acts of kindness
htgshuntthegoodstuff（寻找美好事物）。实际上，在艾比去世后，有人给了我们一张海报，上面写着“接受美好”。我认为这两个短语——“接受美好”和“寻找美好事物”——说明了语言在这里非常重要。我们所谈论的是，尽管发生了这一切，我们仍希望鼓励人们去关注他们世界中依然美好的事物。但我们也鼓励他们寻找适合自己的语言。所以对我说来，你知道的，被告知去数算我的祝福，或者被要求做随机的善举
is just not language that sits well with me, but having this great big pink flurrow poster in our kitchen that says accept the good seemed to do the same job. So I think it's important for people to find the language that works for them. Lucy also realised that language could help her. She was not just a grieving mom and researcher, but a writer, and she found that putting her experience on the page gave her both perspective and comfort. Her writing eventually became a book titled, Resilion Grieving. One of the ideas she explored in the book had to do with how many people deal with grief by asking, why me?
只是不符合我的语言习惯，但在我们厨房里有一张巨大的粉红色毛茸茸海报，上面写着“接受美好”，它似乎起到了同样的作用。所以我认为对人们来说，找到适合他们的语言是很重要的。露西也意识到语言可以帮助她。她不仅仅是一个悲伤的母亲和研究员，还是一个作家，她发现把自己的经历写在纸上既给她带来了视角，也带来了安慰。她的书最终成为了一本名为《有韧性的悲伤》的书。她在书中探讨的一个观点与许多人如何通过问“为什么是我？”来处理悲伤有关。
Lucy came to see that this was counterproductive. She once gave a TED talk to illustrate the idea. She asked people in the audience to do something for her. If you're comfortable, please stand up if any of the following have happened to you, you know, whether it is dementia or whether it is a physical impairment or whether it is cancer or divorce or redundancy, you know, and actually of course within, you know, 30 seconds we've got the whole room standing and the point is to make people realize that adversity doesn't
露西逐渐明白这是适得其反的。她曾做过一次TED演讲来阐明这个观点。她请台下的观众为她做一件事。如果你觉得舒服，如果有以下任何事情发生在你身上，请站起来，你知道的，无论是痴呆症、身体残疾、癌症、离婚还是失业，你知道的，事实上，在30分钟内，整个房间都站了起来，重点是让人意识到逆境并不会
discriminate. You know as much as we don't want this to be true, terrible things happen to us all and knowing that makes it so important to understand how you react in tough times, and to understand the ways of thinking and acting that can help you navigate your darker days. You say that resilient people understand that bad things happen, that suffering is a part of life, and that knowing this keeps them from feeling like victims.
区别对待。你知道，尽管我们不希望这是真的，但可怕的事情都会发生在我们所有人身上，了解这一点使得理解你在艰难时期的反应变得非常重要，并理解那些能够帮助你度过黑暗日期的思考和行动方式。你说过，有韧性的人明白坏事会发生，苦难是生活的一部分，了解这一点可以让他们免于觉得自己是受害者。
Can you expand on this idea, Lucy? What do you mean by that? Yes, I think understanding that everybody suffers in parts of life, you know, that actually very often daily we struggle and suffer and that is absolutely part of the universal existence. Stopped you from feeling singled out and discriminated against when something goes wrong. But critically, it also stopped you from beating yourself up when things go wrong. And so when we live in a, you know,
你能详细阐述这个观点吗，露西？你这是什么意思？是的，我认为明白每个人在生活的某些部分都会受苦，你知道，实际上我们常常每天都在挣扎和受苦，这绝对是普遍存在的一部分。当你出事时，这可以阻止你觉得自己被孤立和区别对待。但至关重要的是，当事情出错时，它也能阻止你自责。所以当我们生活在一个
a era of perfectionism, it's so important for people to understand that, we all stuff up and do things wrong all day long and that doesn't mean we need to be punished, it doesn't mean we're useless, it just means we're human. And this idea actually goes back a really long ways, Lucy. Hidden Brain is a show that's primarily about science, but I can't help but make the connection with the origins of Buddhism, you know, according to the story,
完美主义的时代，让人们明白这一点非常重要：我们整天都会搞砸事情，做错事，但这并不意味着我们需要受到惩罚，并不意味着我们一无是处，这只意味着我们是人类。这个想法实际上可以追溯到很久以前，露西。“隐藏的大脑”是一个主要关于科学的节目，但我忍不住将其与佛教的起源联系起来，你知道的，根据这个故事，
the prince of Dharata is supposed to have seen, you know, people age and suffer and die, and as a result of seeing that, you know, internalize the very idea that you're talking about, which is that suffering, is inevitable. And so in some ways, the lessons that you're talking about here might be, in some ways, confirmed or backed up by modern empirical scientific tools, but there really are really age-old ideas. I couldn't agree more.
达拉塔王子本应看到人们变老、受苦和死去，由于看到了这一点，内化了你正在谈论的那个想法，即苦难是不可避免的。所以在某种程度上，你在这里谈论的教训可能会在某种程度上被现代实证科学工具所证实或支持，但它们确实是非常古老的想法。我完全同意。
And even this element of stoicism in there as well, isn't it? Yeah, we did an episode about stoicism with a philosopher William Irvin, and he had this great line, do what you can with what you have where you are. And it's the same idea, which is we can only do what we can do, but if we pay attention to what we can do, that's not nothing. Yeah, absolutely.
其中甚至还有这种斯多葛主义的成分，不是吗？是的，我们和哲学家威廉·欧文做过一期关于斯多葛主义的节目，他有一句很棒的话：在你的地方，用你拥有的东西，尽你所能。这也是同样的道理，也就是我们只能做我们能做的事，但如果我们关注我们能做的事，那并不是什么都没做。是的，绝对的。
And in all of our work, we always encourage people to focus on the things that matter and the things that they can control. And, you know, that's very similar. As Lucy looked for ways to apply these insights in her day-to-day life, she started to seek opportunities to find serenity, pride, and awe. Yes, I do remember taking myself off into the hills to do a walk one day and standing there in the really kind of big mountainous kind of landscape of New Zealand and that made me feel better because I kind of felt like when you're in that and surrounded by majesty on that kind of brand scale it makes you feel smaller and I found that really helpful.
在我们所有的工作中，我们总是鼓励人们关注重要的事情以及他们能控制的事情。你知道，这非常相似。当露西在日常生活中寻找应用这些见解的方法时，她开始寻找获得平静、自豪感和敬畏感的机会。是的，我确实记得有一天自己去山里散步，站在新西兰那种真正浩瀚宏大的山地风景中，这让我感觉好多了，因为我有一种感觉，当你身处其中，被那种宏大壮丽所环绕时，你会觉得自己变小了，我发现这真的很有帮助。
And somebody recently in one of our courses was just saying to me, I've done exactly the same thing by visiting a cathedral or a park, so you know, getting out there into nature. I also used to attend my boys rugby matches to go and be kind of inspired and feel proud of them. And I used to listen to Desert Island Discs, which is a BBC radio podcast, because that kind of checkered life journey that people go on would give me hope.
最近我们课程中的某个人对我说：我也做过完全相同的事情，去参观大教堂或公园，所以你知道，去大自然中走走。我过去也经常去参加我男孩们的橄榄球比赛，去寻找灵感，为他们感到骄傲。我过去常常听《荒岛唱片》，这是BBC广播的一个播客，因为人们所经历的曲折人生旅程会给我带来希望。
So just different little ways of bringing those positive emotions back into my everyday life. Is it possible that some people resist doing those things because they almost feel guilty about doing them? They might worry, are other people going to say, you know, she's just lost her daughter, what is she doing at a restaurant, or what is she doing watching a movie, that again, we are compelled to follow the scripts presented to us about how we're supposed to grieve
所以只是用不同的小方法把那些积极的情绪带回我的日常生活中。有没有可能有些人抵触做这些事情，因为他们做这些事情时几乎感到内疚？他们可能会担心：其他人会说“她刚失去女儿，她在餐馆里干什么，或者她在看什么电影”吗？我们再次被迫遵循关于我们应该如何悲伤的剧本
and deal with loss and trauma. Exactly. That is what people say and experience. That they feel judged and feel guilty for experiencing any form of positive emotions, for laughing with friends or wanting to go out and see a movie or just be out, you know, enjoying themselves. Isn't it a shame that so much of what is kind of out there and expected of grief
以及如何处理失去和创伤。完全正确。这就是人们所说和经历的。他们因为体验到任何形式的积极情绪、因为和朋友大笑或想要出去看电影或只是出去享受生活而感到被评判和内疚。真遗憾，很多关于悲伤的既定看法和期望竟然是
is that you just have to be miserable for a long time and that if you're experiencing positive experiences, there's something wrong with you when actually we know that that is, you know, so far from the truth. So your work has attracted a lot of interest Lucy and obviously there are people who are deeply moved by your story and your insights about healthy grieving. But some people might hear you saying that you want people who are at the lowest points in their lives to pull themselves up by their bootstraps, that grieving people need to be responsible for their own emotional recovery. Is that an accurate representation of your work?
你只需要痛苦很长一段时间，如果你正在经历积极的体验，说明你出了问题，而实际上我们知道这与事实相去甚远。所以你的工作吸引了很多人，露西，显然有很多人被你的故事以及你对健康悲伤的见解深深打动。但有些人可能会听到你说，你希望处于人生低谷的人自己振作起来，认为悲伤的人需要对他们自己的情感恢复负责。这是对你工作的准确描述吗？
Is that an accurate representation of your work? Oh, I certainly hope not. No, I think I really do make a very deliberate point in resilient grieving to say to people, never am I trying to put more pressure on the bereaved. Wow, you know, that would be furtherest from my intention. All of our work is created for people who come to us saying thank you for validating my desire to be an active participant in my own grief journey. And so we know that
这是对你工作的准确描述吗？哦，我当然希望不是。不，我认为我在《有韧性的悲伤》中确实非常刻意地对人们说：我绝不是在试图给丧亲者施加更多的压力。哇，你知道，那将最不符合我的初衷。我们所有的工作都是为那些对我们说“谢谢你认可我想要成为自己悲伤之旅的积极参与者的愿望”的人创作的。所以我们知道
so many people now are looking for ways to support them through that adaptation to loss. And so we're not forcing people and we always say to people, here actually these are all of the theoretically sound and scientifically backed strategies that we've come across, try some of these out for yourself. See what works for you. Be your own personal experiment and find the grief journey that works for you. So I think that giving people a prescription for hope, I think is the number one aim of our work.
现在有这么多人正在寻找方法来支持他们度过对失去的适应期。所以我们没有强迫人们，我们总是对人们说：实际上，这些都是我们遇到的所有在理论上合理且有科学依据的策略，你自己尝试一下其中的一些。看看什么对你有效。做你自己的个人实验，找到适合你的悲伤之旅。所以我认为给人们开出希望的处方是我们工作的第一目标。
You lost your daughter, in 2014 and you've written about how it's a mistake to think that time shrinks grief but time does do something else. Can you tell me your insight about the circles around your grief? Yes, so this came from a local grief counselor, and her theory is that the bereaved often think that their grief or their toll that their grief will shrink over time. But yet what really happens is that your grief stays the same and your world, your life grows around it. You know, seven years we are on now from Abbey's death and I can
你在2014年失去了女儿，你写过关于认为时间会缩短悲伤是一个错误的文章，但时间确实做了别的事情。你能告诉我你对围绕你悲伤的圈子的见解吗？是的，这来自当地的一位悲伤咨询师，她的理论是，丧亲者常常认为他们的悲伤或悲伤的代价会随着时间的推移而缩短。然而真正发生的是，你的悲伤保持不变，而你的世界、你的生活围绕着它生长。你知道，距离艾比去世现在已经七年了，我可以
notice how our world has grown beyond her, you know, as much as I'd love to have her with us. There are new experiences and new people in our world who won't around when she was here. And so I can see that life literally has grown around her and her loss. And she will always be in my heart, all of our hearts. And we carry her forward, we'll never forget her. But life grows and goes on. And as long as she's with us and we have her legacy, then I don't want to say that that's okay,
注意到我们的世界是如何超越她生长的，你知道的，尽管我很想让她和我们在一起。我们的世界有了新的经历和新的人，在她在这里时他们并不在。所以我可以看到生活确实围绕着她和她的失去在生长。她将永远在我心中，在我们所有人的心中。我们带着她前进，永远不会忘记她。但生活在成长并继续。只要她和我们在一起，我们拥有她的遗产，那么我不想说这没关系，
because it's not, but I guess it's good enough. Lucy Hone is a public health researcher and practitioner in New Zealand. She's the author of Resilient Grieving, finding strength and embracing life after a loss that changes everything. Lucy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me, Shankar, and for all you in your listeners' time.
因为这不是，但我想这已经足够好了。露西·霍恩是新西兰的一名公共卫生研究员和实践者。她是《有韧性的悲伤：在改变一切的失去之后寻找力量并拥抱生活》一书的作者。露西，谢谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我，尚卡尔，也谢谢你和你的听众的时间。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week in our Healing 2. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week in our Healing 2.0 series, we bring you a very different story about grief. We'll talk with a man who took a radical step when he learned his mother was dying. I think it's fair to say that I was the most prepared human being in the history of the world to lose a loved one.
“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德リュー·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行主编。下周在我们的“疗愈2.0”系列中，我们将为你带来一个关于悲伤的截然不同的故事。我们将与一位在得知母亲垂死时采取了激进措施的男子交谈。我认为公平地说，我是人类历史上为失去亲人准备得最充分的人。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。